british and european negotiators will
today resume
talks to secure a post-brexit trade deal
with an agreement hanging
in the balance the latest round of talks
is taking place in brussels ahead of an
eu summit
later this week the eu is offering
tariff-free
access to the single market in exchange
for britain agreeing to eu
rules on state aid environmental and
labor
regulations britain will leave the
single market trading block at the end
of this month
and for the very latest let's go over to
brussels dw's barbara basil is standing
by for us there hi barbara good to see
you so
negotiations they were tense over the
weekend they're resuming today
has any progress been made no progress
has been made
because from what just emerged by a very
early morning briefing
by michel barnier the eu elite
negotiator
to the european ambassadors who are the
point people
of the member states here in brussels
there is
not a mood of victory absolutely not
talks are slow talks are difficult
they are dragging on and there has been
no breakthrough we heard last night that
supposedly
somehow on fisheries the two sides had
come together
but that was uh as so often before in
these
uh in this drama it was a false
hope and so they're continuing
throughout the day
well that's not a good sign we know that
the british prime minister boris johnson
and the european commission president
jose lafonda line they will evaluate
tonight whether enough progress really
has been made
now barbara you mentioned the fisheries
but remind us what the biggest sticking
points are right now
nothing has moved on the three big
questions you mentioned already the
the level playing field that's what we
call a fair competition
that is britain has to sort of more or
less acknowledge the rules that the
european union has
on environment labor laws and so on a
very
big bound of contention is the question
of governance
the eu wants rather tight clauses to
punish the united kingdom
if they sort of don't obey the rules
of the agreement in the end something
that we have seen was the withdrawal
agreement
and that is another big problem it will
be coming back the
contentious internal market law it will
be coming back into
parliament today in london and
supposedly be voted through
that is a point for the european union
where they say if you
don't stick to the first agreement we
did how can we ever believe
that you will stick to the second
agreement we you do
so there is a complete lack of trust and
then of course there
is fishery they can't agree on how and
where and how much the two sides the
fissures of two of the two sides
will be allowed to use each other's
waters and what fish to pull out
and just quickly barbara if they don't
get a deal what happens
it will be the mother of all
catastrophes we will have trucks stacked
up
to the horizon on in calais on end dover
of course
everything will break down we'll need
emergency agreements on
aviation on transport for trucks to be
able to roll at
all um the the whole cooperation between
the uk
and the united uh and the european union
40 years of it will suddenly all be void
and they will really have to scramble to
sort of come across
the first of january of next year it
will be a very difficult time
all of that hanging in the balance today
dw's bhagavad-girl for us
in brussels thank you